[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cet ouragan monstrueux et le plus fort
jamais enregistré dans l'océan
atlantique et dans les caraïbes il a
tout dévasté sur son passage
c'était en septembre dernier par bouddha
une petite île des caraïbes est ravagé
par trois ouragans successifs
irma classé en catégorie 5 la plus
élevée du josé et maria
[Musique]
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre la
pollution de l'air réchauffe la planète
à une vitesse encore jamais atteinte
dans l'histoire de l'humanité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et les conséquences sont de plus en plus
effrayante
les caraïbes sont en première ligne
les gens deviennent plus forts et plus
gros carrés absorbe l'humidité ce que
produisent et des mères de plus en plus
chaude à cause du réchauffement
climatique
[Musique]
voici une image de l'oeil de droit gants
et cette petite île au milieu c'est
barbuda les autorités annoncent que 90%
de l'inde pourraient avoir disparu
[Musique]
de barbuda a été décimé toute sa
population et sans-abri et ses bâtiments
transformés en trop qui vident
j'étais dans ma maison et j'ai entendu
un énorme bruit non comme une explosion
explose
oui avec nous sommes les cobayes du
changement climatique les futures
générations pourront nous prendre en
exemple et apprendre comment réagir
bouda ce n'est pas simplement une
catastrophe naturelle c'est une crise
humanitaire qui peuvent ruiner notre
pays
les barbus dhien ont été contraints de
fuir leur île détruite par les ouragans
série
sont devenus les premiers déplacés
climatiques des caraïbes
ils ont tout perdu tout abandonner
1600 personnes réfugiées dans l'île
voisine d'an thillois
déracinés qui s'entassent dans des
refuges de fortune
sans savoir quand ils pourront revenir
construire leur île
[Musique]
leur exemple sera-t-il prendre
conscience de la fragilité de notre
planète
les preuves du réchauffement climatique
sont maintenant irréfutables
il
au petit matin dans le port de saint
john sur l'île d'antigua dans les
caraïbes une quarantaine de personnes se
prépare à embarquer
[Musique]
ce sont des habitants de l'île voisine
de barbuda
pour la première fois depuis le passage
de l'ouragan les autorités viennent de
les autoriser à se rendre sur place pour
constater les dégâts
seule l'armée présente sur l'île depuis
le désastre
ça fait plaisir de rentrer à la maison
randall chf 57 ans est professeur à la
retraite il emporte beaucoup d'eau et
des produits de première nécessité ici
personne ne sait à quoi s'attendre
là nous les baroudeurs nous sommes des
gens résilient et fort et je suis sûr
que grâce à cela et à l'aide de dieu
nous allons nous en sortir oui mais
après
j'espère que je vais arriver à revoir ma
maison et voir comment avancer
mais je m'attends au pire
il n'y a plus d'électricité pas d'eau
courante
mais pour la rendre potable nous allons
la faire bouillir trouver de quoi nous
débrouiller je suis sûr que ça va aller
barbuda se trouve à deux heures de
navigation d'antibois mais tous sur ce
bateau savent que plus rien ne sera
comme avant
ce sont tous des survivants leurs
paradis tropical s'est transformé en
enfer
pas sûr
[Musique]
la colère de dieu s'est abattue sur
barbuda
des vents de plus de 300 km/heure des
vents soutenus
je n'avais jamais vécu quelque chose
comme ça dans ma vie
et pour quand j'étais là-bas en 95 quand
loi dans louis s'est passé
mais ça n'était rien en comparaison avec
celui ci
ensuite ils nous ont forcés à évacuer
car un autre ouragan arrivé sur nous
alors au lieu d'en prendre en pleine
figure on nous a demandé de fuir avant
d'or noir
[Musique]
et fritz akanua
jamais l'écart elle n'avait connu
pareille situation
début septembre après irma l'ouragan
josé se rapproche de barbuda
[Musique]
oui
les autorités prennent alors une
décision inédite
vider l'île de ses habitants
1600 personnes évacuées par avion dans
l'île voisine d'an ti goy
les ordres sont claires l'état d'urgence
a été déclaré alors ceux qui veulent
rester malgré tout ils seront arrêtés et
poursuivis en justice
randall fle professeur à la retraite et
parmi eux ici en tee-shirt orange
certains habitants étaient forcés à
quitter leurs maisons mais l'évacuation
générale a permis de sauver la
population de barbuda
[Musique]
un mois plus tard une poignée
d'habitants va tenter de faire le bilan
des dégâts
[Musique]
ce ponton a tenu bon c'est le seul de
toute l'île
[Musique]
et
je peux mettre ça à l'arrière du camion
depuis le passage de l'ouragan lille est
resté figé en ruines
presque aucune construction n'a résisté
lille est toujours inhabitable
[Musique]
un mois après le drame il n'y a ni eau
ni électricité seules les routes ont été
dégagées
les inondations provoquées une
prolifération de moustiques
il tour à tour colonisée par les
espagnols les français puis les anglais
vivait presque exclusivement du tourisme
et de la pêche
elle était prisé par les riches sont
anglo saxons pour ses plages de rêve
préserver elle comptait une école un
hôpital une dizaine de restaurants
tout a été balayé par les ouragans à
répétition
[Musique]
c'est incroyable qu'il n'est pas une
mort lors du premier ouragan
parce que lille est totalement dévastée
voilà le centre de barbuda
ici c'était le madison square garden il
y avait des bars des restaurants des
salons de beauté
coq chapsa juste là
[Musique]
des hôtels dévastée partout des maisons
sans toi
et voici la sienne c'est l'une des rares
dont la toiture a tenu bon
mon dieu ça fait plaisir de voir ça
l'aide ce poteau là il était là bas il
s'est cassé il est venu frapper ma
maison ici
avant de quitter l'île après le passage
dire ma toutes les maisons étaient
scellées par leurs habitants pour éviter
les pillages
tous les habitants ont été contraints
d'évacuer avant l'arrivée de l'ouragan
josé
la vitre n'a pas tenu le coup elle s'est
brisée
mais tout est sec
[Musique]
[Rires]
quatorze personnes sont venues ici le
soir de l'ouragan sa maison était
fragile et le lendemain matin elle avait
été détruite
mon fils et sa femme et mes petits
enfants ils ont tout perdu alors ils
sont tous venus se réfugier ici
la maison a tenu bon face aux trois
ouragans successifs mais il leur faudra
des jours pour tout nettoyer
les deux voitures de rands half porte
les traces de la violence de l'ouragan
au moins tout est là
sa femme vient de se rendre compte que
barbuda risque de rester inhabitable
pendant de longues semaines encore
ça fait du bien d'être de retour chez
soi mais on va avoir beaucoup de travail
la maison étant bazar mais c'est
chouette d'être revenu c'est dommage de
ne pas pouvoir rester sur l'île mais on
va avancer un pas après l'autre c'est
bon de revoir barbuda j'ai juste du mal
à la reconnaître
mais c'est par bout d'un autre maison
face à l'ampleur des dégâts
randall fait désemparés
demain cela fera un mois
mais lille est presque resté en état
les routes ont bien été nettoyées mais
il ya des débris partout
m'attendais à ce que la situation soit
bien meilleure
beaucoup de pays sont venus à notre
secours
où sont les deux nations ne vois rien
de neige
un mois après la catastrophe et nous
devrions déjà voir les matériaux arrivé
pour la construction mais je ne vois
rien du tout vous voulez rester à
barbuda mais moi c'est ma maison je vais
rester ici
[Musique]
mais son il est aujourd'hui totalement
inhabitable pour combien de temps encore
en un mois désertée par ses habitants
elle est redevenu sauvage les animaux y
vivent en liberté des centaines de
chiens ont été abandonnés par leurs
propriétaires
en l'absence des habitants les pluies à
répétition fini de ravager les maisons
endommagées
[Musique]
de race
voilà ma maison
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
taiwan elle a tout perdu
aujourd'hui c'est son anniversaire
elle a 73 ans
[Musique]
voilà la réserve dans mon magasin
tout est gâché
je vendais de tout même des habits des
uniformes d'écolier
[Applaudissements]
après le passage des ouragans la pluie a
détruit tout son stock où pullulent
aujourd'hui mouches et moustiques
je ne sais pas quoi faire je veux juste
que les gens dans le monde sache ce qui
s'est passé ici
ils auraient dû nous laisser revenir une
semaine après l'ouragan parce qu'on
aurait pu sauver beaucoup de nos biens
mais ne nous ont pas autorisés à revenir
nous ont parqué antigua va nous
permettre de revenir sauver nos affaires
cela ne fait que quelques jours que les
autorités disent avoir dégagé les routes
depuis un mois seuls les militaires
étaient autorisés sur l'île le sergent
rennais 55 ans assure le maintien de
l'ordre
je ne peux même pas imaginer la
souffrance de ces gens leur douleur en
fait ce sont des réfugiés climatiques
maintenant en chef exactement alors il
faut penser efficace
la france a bien sûr que je suis triste
je me sens impuissant ne pas pouvoir les
aider davantage
alors qu'ils ont perdu le peu qu'ils
avaient
être ici et voir tout ça ce n'est pas
facile mais au moins je peux tenter de
les aider ça me donne de l'espoir qu'au
moins quelque chose est fait et les gens
ont hâte que les choses s'améliorent
dans cette partie de l'île les terres
agricoles proches de l'océan ont été
inondées par la mer déchaînée
ici rien ne pourra repousser avant des
années
ce que vous voyez là bas c'était une
superbe plantation de cocotiers
regardez la quantité d'arbres des
milliers sont perdus il va falloir les
déracinés et en replanter d'autres
et ce sera difficile car à cause de la
quantité d'heures celle apportée par la
mer la zone est devenue très compliquée
à cultiver
s
la petite unité de militaires qui
dirigent et chargée de contrôler
l'arrivée des bateaux qui débarquent sur
l'île les habitants ne sont pas encore
autorisés à rester dormir sur place
combien de passagers sur le bateau j'en
ai compté 94
nous avons une petite équipe médicale et
qui ne peut donner que les premiers
soins nous n'avons rien pour les
personnes qui pourraient avoir un
problème de santé ici à cause d'un
simple diabète ou un souci
cardiovasculaires alors ils ont fait
savoir aux habitants qui veulent venir
sur l'île que nous allons vérifier
qu'ils repartent bien le même jour à
antigua là où il y à un véritable
hôpital
[Musique]
à la nuit tombée le sergent et ses
soldats sont les seuls habitants de
barbuda
[Musique]
une quinzaine de personnes isolées du
monde une petite communauté autonome qui
se serrent les coudes
alors est-ce que ça sent bon
[Musique]
ce soir c'est moi qui cuisine mais je
vais d'abord goûter avant de donner la
troupe on verra si m c'est notre manière
de survivre ici
un petit groupe soudé conscient d'avoir
en charge les clés d'un paradis détruits
[Musique]
nous avions les plus belles plages vous
savez malheureusement à cause de la
montée des eaux elles ont été salis mais
c'est toujours notre paradis
et il remettra un jour j'en suis sûr
[Musique]
il
il est 6h30 le lendemain matin lorsque
le sergent rennais se rend à l'aérodrome
de barbuda
la piste est très courte
la tour de contrôle est hors service
il ne dispose pas de radio pour prévenir
le pilote art ni le guider
le sergent est chargé de veiller à
l'atterrissage périlleux de cet appareil
[Musique]
nous n'avons aucun moyen de
communication avec l'avion alors notre
présence ici est nécessaire pour assurer
la sécurité de tout le monde
un mois après le drame rares sont les
ong internationales présentes à barbuda
ce matin cet avion est une bonne
nouvelle il est chargé de plusieurs
dizaines de générateurs le vol est
affrété par samaritan purse une
association caritative américaine la
seule à disposer d'un avion de cette
taille
ses sauts blanc ce sont de petites
unités de filtration nous avons aussi
des générateurs et des bidons d'essence
mais le plus important c'est la
cargaison de générateurs qui comptent
aider les gens à avoir de l'électricité
dans leur maison jusqu'à ce que le
principal système remise en état
elles vont devoir filtrer eux-mêmes
l'euro car l'eau des puits qu'ils
étaient habitués à boire est aujourd'hui
contaminés à cause de la pluie animaux
morts le ph est affecté et seul impact
énormément sa potabilité
tu vas la jeep je peux tout donné ça moi
je termine avec le chargement
un mois après le passage de l'ouragan la
d'international manque cruellement à
barbuda ces générateurs seront les
premiers à être distribués aux habitants
bien sûr on a plus que jamais besoin d
aide nos ressources sont très limités
alors plus on arrivera en obtenir mieux
ce sera pour le déblaiement des débris
mais aussi pour l' expertise des
bâtiments endommagés
plus d'une personne ne veut repartir
avec moi
allez au revoir merci
pas de personnel non plus pour les
manoeuvres de décollage
à barbuda aujourd'hui il faut savoir
tout faire soi même
[Musique]
l'île est aujourd'hui isolées oubliées
du reste du monde
écrasée sous le poids des destructions
sont moyens pour tout reconstruire
j'ai été déployé dans le mississippi au
moment de l'ouragan katrina
mais c'étaient les états unis un grand
pays avec énormément d'infrastructures
alors imaginer ici tout petit je ne
pense pas qu'un millier de téléphone
portable sur cette île puisse être
suffisamment rentable pour payer ça
mahmoud est la grande oubliée des
caraïbes pas de réseau téléphonique à
attendre avant des semaines ni
d'électricité
alors les quelques habitants présents
sur l'île sont venus aux nouvelles nous
retrouvons taille rennes qui a fêté ses
soixante treize ans hier elle est venue
chercher son cadeau d'anniversaire un
générateur pour sa maison
esther sa voisine elle aussi veut tenter
de s'installer durablement
nous avons seulement réussi à sauver le
matériel électroménager le reste est
foutu
je suis vraiment désolé c'est un
désastre
j'ai demandé aux autorités juste après
l'évacuation que nous fassions la même
chose que lors du dernier ouragan que
nous retournions sur place pour nettoyer
que tout le monde s'y met et senna ça il
faut qu'il laisse les gens revenir
maintenant pour reconstruire barbuda
devons tous revenir parce que la pluie
détruit tout ce qui reste
dans combien de temps les habitants de
barbuda pourront-ils revenir chez eux
ils ont tous été déplacée à antigua les
deux îles voisines forme d'un même état
antigua été épargnée par le cyclone elle
vit elle aussi du tourisme avec ses
plages de rêve
la saison va bientôt commencer les
vacanciers vont affluer du monde entier
pour profiter de ses charmes tropicaux
à saint john la capitale la tragédie de
barbuda et silencieuse elle ne se voit
pas
après le drame un vaste mouvement de
solidarité s'est organisée pour venir en
aide aux réfugiés
les barbadiens qui n'ont pas été
accueillis chez un proche ont été logés
dans le stade municipal
[Musique]
plusieurs centaines de personnes y
vivent hommes et femmes de tous âges et
des dizaines d'enfants
une vie entre parenthèses de déraciner
un stade vide pour une vie en transition
encore hanté par les frayeurs de
l'ouragan
dans le stade les vestiaires ont été
transformés en dortoirs
hommes et femmes dorment séparer
[Musique]
au fil des semaines les réfugiés se sont
organisés chacun avec des tâches
précises
propreté approvisionnement cuisine
sonnette prépare les repas du midi
depuis un mois à 22 ans elle espérait
entrer à l'université pour devenir
infirmière l'ouragan a bouleversé ses
projets
je suis contente de travailler un peu
nous sommes sains et sauf maintenant je
suis prête à tout affronter peu importe
ce qu'il va arriver
et à
personne ici ne sais combien de temps
ils devront rester dans ce stade à faire
la file pour un plat de cantine
sur les visages des évacués de barbuda
beaucoup de lassitude
[Musique]
tiens c'est pour toi je pourrais avoir
une assiette aussi un avenir en miettes
pour la jeune génération de barbuda
[Musique]
et une pour moi s'il vous plaît mais
ioniques et hakim 9 et 8 ans son frère
et soeur les vêtements qu'ils portent
proviennent de donations
d'encarta me manque et mes jolis livres
et mes chaussures
moi mon il me manque ma maison mes
habits aussi mes chaussures mais surtout
ma télévision aussi
on avait une télé avec un énorme écran
mais tout a été détruit
[Musique]
des enfants durablement marqué par le
passage des ouragans
[Musique]
il ya un truc qui a volé comme ça 6-6
nous avons dû fuir parce que notre toit
allait s'envoler nous sommes allés nous
réfugier dans une maison en brique et là
à la fenêtre j'ai vu notre maison et je
crois que notre toit a tenu
[Musique]
oui il a bien tenu
[Applaudissements]
unique et ses amis font partie de la
première génération de déplacés
climatiques à grandir en exil avec pour
maison un stade de cricket et des
tribunes comme salle à manger
[Applaudissements]
les barbadiens sans test dans les
couloirs transformer en territoire de
jeu par les enfants
mais après un mois ici les adultes
supporte de moins en moins cet
enfermement
voilà où vivent marianne et ses quatre
enfants
dans ce petit vestiaire transformé en
dortoir où se serrent 13 personnes cinq
adultes et huit enfants
je ne supporte plus cette situation
seulement je pouvais avoir un autre
endroit où aller pour sortir d'ici aller
ailleurs ici en plus il ya beaucoup de
gens qui volent nos affaires vous savez
[Applaudissements]
le provisoire est en train de devenir
permanent
la générosité des habitants de antigua
envers les barbadiens pourtant ne se
dément pas
ce sont les employés du stade qui gère
l'hébergement des déplacés et la
réception des donations
mais pour alimenter plusieurs centaines
de personnes l'approvisionnement reste
compliqué
denise harris la directrice du stade ne
sait plus où donner de la tête
[Musique]
nous ne savons pas combien de temps cela
va durer peu importe que nous voulons
c'est qu'ils se sentent à leur aise sans
stress bien sûr ils se sentiront jamais
comme chez eux mais au moins ici on se
sent bien
elle a besoin d'une centaine de kilos de
pâtes de riz de sucre pour alimenter les
barbes ou dix ans chaque semaine
dans l'île ces volontaires sont
conscients désormais d'être les victimes
du changement climatique
si nous continuons de vivre ainsi de
polluer la planète l'otsi on ne se
préoccupe pas de cela quand les petites
îles vont souffrir non définitive cela
impactera aussi les grandes villes car
si nous nous avons des ouragans ils
auront des tremblements de terre des
radiations solaires et bien d'autres
phénomènes de ce genre nous devons y
prêter attention famille
[Musique]
les jours passent et dont le stade tous
les matins taylor suis toujours la même
routine
[Musique]
un café pour son épouse encore endormis
dans le dortoir qu'il partage avec dix
autres personnes
[Musique]
et après le café latentes sur les
gradins interminable taylor est
menuisier il a 52 ans
tous les matins il regarde les enfants
se préparait à partir pour l'école pour
ne pas interrompre leur scolarité
sa maison a été balayée par les vents
violents il sait qu'il ne pourra pas la
reconstruire seul à la banque ces
économies ne suffiront pas pour payer
les travaux aujourd'hui il est devenu
prisonnier du stade transformé en refuge
[Musique]
nevis c'est la liberté que nous avions
qui me manque le plus
quand nous habitions là bas je me
sentais en paix
nikos
notre terre et notre héritage nous y
sommes très attachés
[Musique]
alors on a dû nous arracher de là bas
je veux dire dans une autre île et c'est
pour nous une étape très difficile à
passer
[Musique]
and is yours
la jeune génération de barbuda elle ne
se laisse pas envahir par la nostalgie
partir à l'école à antigua et déjà
devenu une routine pour ses enfants
il
tu préfère être ici ou à barbuda toi
moi je préfère ici
parce que notre école est jolie
et et j'avais toujours rêvé devenir
antigua
[Musique]
s'y installer pour ne plus jamais en
repartir c'est la hantise des bars
bodian
dans l'île d'antigua d'autres petits
refuges ont surgi les semaines ont passé
avec elle les frustrations
les réfugiés accueillis dans un premier
temps dans leurs familles viennent à
présent s'y installer dans cette école
vivent plus de 120 personnes samantha
gère le refuge elle est payée par le
gouvernement
les autres employés sont volontaires ici
les conditions sont encore plus précaire
que dans le stade
vous savez ce qu'il s'est passé
[Applaudissements]
tenez et buvez
avec la chaleur tropicale et sans
climatisation
il fait plus de 30 degrés dans ce
dortoir cette vieille dame n'a pas
supporté vous pouvez faire quelque chose
avec les ventilateurs et fait très chaud
là
[Applaudissements]
ça va être compliqué là
à cause de son âge elle est susceptible
d'attraper plein de maladies ici c'est
une gastro entérite n'importe quel virus
contagieux mais il me semble que là
c'est simplement un malaise à cause de
la chaleur il fait très chaud c'est
humide voulait redonner quelque chose de
frais à boire et avec quelque chose à
manger elle valait beaucoup mieux
j'espère
la nuit quand le dortoir est plein la
chaleur est bien pire encore avec les
maigres moyens attribués au refuge
samantha n'a pas le budget pour acheter
plusieurs dizaines de climatisation pour
ses dortoirs
voilà notre supermarché
samantha à coordonner la collecte de
vêtements antigua les déplacés de toute
l'île viennent s'y approvisionner rien
n'était prévu pour faire face à cette
situation inédite antibois n'était pas
prête à absorber autant de réfugiés
[Musique]
je crois que ma vie d'avant et terminé à
cause des ouragans et du changement
climatique
évidemment oui et tout le reste
nous allons devoir affronter bien pire
cet ouragan il était énorme je n'avais
jamais vu un ouragan d'une telle force
de toute ma vie
maintenant vous devons supporter les
conséquences
[Musique]
après des semaines de travail la fatigue
s'accumule les prochains mois seront
encore plus difficiles
l'incertitude grandit chez les bars
bodian coincé sur antigua sans
ressources repartir sur l'île par est
impossible à 56 ans louisette et
cuisinière dans un hôtel de barbuda
cette grand mère élève seule ses quatre
petits enfants
c'est une décision difficile je ne sais
pas si je suis prête à antigua et
barbuda nous formons un seul pays c'est
notre deuxième maison oui j'adore
barbuda je mourrai pour mon île mais
dans cette situation
certes un peu d'attenté d'y aller mais
moi je ne peux pas tant que la maison
n'est pas réparé avec l'eau courante et
l'électricité
c'est normal non
le coût de la reconstruction est estimé
à plus de 200 millions d'euros plus d'un
quart de la richesse annuelle de ce
petit état insulaire
une somme astronomique impossible à
financer antigua n'est pas riche elle
n'a pas les moyens de payer seuls
sa population ne compte que cent mille
habitants aux faibles revenus ils vivent
eux aussi dans des conditions précaires
[Musique]
pour faire face aux dépenses d'urgence à
barbuda le premier ministre a demandé
l'aide internationale
mais ils peinent à mobiliser il a
accepté de nous recevoir
[Musique]
ces messieurs désolé de vous avoir fait
attendre je suis très occupé en ce
moment
gaston mme brown dénonce le
réchauffement climatique depuis des
années ils en appellent à la solidarité
des pays riches les plus gros pollueurs
selon lui les responsables de ce qui est
arrivé à barbuda
[Musique]
et je dois avouer que nous n'avons pas
reçu beaucoup de grands pays ne se sont
pas mobilisés
alors que comme je les dis dans le passé
ce sont tous les plus grands
consommateurs d'énergie fossile ce qui
contribue au changement climatique qui
rend des mers plus chaudes avec des
tempêtes et des ouragans de plus en plus
frais taux est féroce
et dans le même temps je ne vois pas ces
pays prendre leurs responsabilités nous
dédommager pour les pertes et les dégâts
[Musique]
alors combien de temps prendra la
reconstruction de barbuda des mois des
années
la solidarité s'organise avec de
modestes moyens
dans le port d'antibes bois ce matin un
bateau se prépare à partir pour barbuda
[Musique]
karen 72 ans fait partie des passagers
c'est l'infatigable présidente de la
société de protection des animaux
elle doit empêcher que les chiens
revenus à l'état sauvage nos rendre
l'île inhabitable
le principal problème à barbuda en ce
moment ce sont les chiens errants
abandonnés par leurs maîtres ils sont en
liberté ils font ce que les chiens
sauvages font toujours ils se regroupent
en me qui chassent et tuent les autres
animaux comme le bétail
[Musique]
avec elle ce matin kevin un vétérinaire
anglais accompagnés par une équipe de
spécialistes envoyés par l'omg donkey
sanctuary
deux heures de navigation sur une mer
turquoise qui ne portent plus de traces
de l'ouragan
[Musique]
oui
l'équipe est chargée d' isoler les
chiens malades ou agressif et de les
rapporter antigua pour être soigné
karen attend aussi du matériel pour
construire des chenils
[Musique]
sur l'île de très nombreux chiens vivent
aujourd'hui en liberté et risquent de
contaminer les humains
kevin le vétérinaire sait comment les
amadouer pour pouvoir les examiner
qu'est-ce que vous vérifiez là je
regarde leur gueule pour connaître leur
état de santé c'est une procédure
élémentaire ces chiens sont très bien
éduqués ils sont très doux le problème
ici ce sont les meutes de chiens mais
ceux là sont très gentils
on cherche un chien en particulier qui a
un abcès à cause d'une morsure on va
essayer de nous trouver avant qui nous
échappe mais regardez comme ils sont
beaux
oh non les chiens blessés passe sur la
table celui ci a six mois à peine sa
mâchoire et gravement infectés mais
kevin a apporté d'angleterre de quoi
tenir quelques jours en médicaments
il attrape facilement des parasites des
verts ensuite viennent les mouches il se
gratte et ça devient très vite moche une
plaie non traités c'est la recette pour
un désastre
c'est celui qu'ont cherché non
oui c'est celui-là allez on embarque
vite
pourquoi
dans
lui aussi vient de perdre provisoirement
sa liberté mais il devrait retrouver son
propriétaire d'ici quelques jours
l'équipe qui accompagne kevin le
vétérinaire est chargé d'évaluer l'état
de l'aérodrome rendu impraticable lui
aussi à cause des animaux errants
[Musique]
mais la situation est encore pire que ce
qu'ils avaient prévu
[Musique]
les gens vont revenir pour se rendre
compte qu'il ne reste rien de leur
maison
on ne sait pas par quoi commencer
problème je ne vois pas comment c'est en
tout cas si l'on arrive à remettre en
état la barrière qui protège l'aéroport
alors au moins les avions et les
hélicoptères pourront se poser en toute
sécurité ce sera un début
[Musique]
l'aérodrome est toujours dans le même
état des troupes de mule circulent
librement sur la piste barbuda on compte
plus de 2000
[Musique]
l'équipe doit évaluer le plus rapidement
possible comment isoler la piste de ces
animaux sauvages
[Musique]
c'est la seule piste de barbuda toutes
les barrières ont été détruites soufflée
par le vent
les animaux sont installés sur la piste
d'envol c'est un risque trop grand pour
n'importe quel avion qui voudraient
atterrir
ça limite l'aide humanitaire qui
pourrait rapidement venir par avion
comme un abus des mules des ânes des
chevaux et des chiens bien sûr
premier essai mais les mules sont
ingérables indomptables
et les abords de la piste sont encore
inondées impraticable pour un véhicule
mais john ancien soldat de l'armée
britannique est optimiste
je pense que l'on va pouvoir au moins
redresser ces barrières qui ont été
couchés par le vent et moins d'arrivées
isolé au moins sept zones éloignées les
animaux temporairement le temps de
réparer le reste
leur tâche sera longue la piste va
rester difficilement accessibles pendant
plusieurs semaines encore
pourtant il ya urgence plus le temps
passe plus lille se détériore la
d'international arrivent au compte
goutte les habitants se débrouille avec
les moyens du bord
[Applaudissements]
karen la présidente de l'association de
protection des animaux attendait cette
barge depuis plusieurs jours
ce sont les derniers matériaux dont
j'avais besoin les briques et les
pierres ça progresse enfin
tout cela va nous servir pour construire
des chenils pour les chiens
les brics et pour isoler les animaux
qu'ils ne puissent pas passer à travers
le grillage ils pourront se voir mais
pas se battre
les chiens errants s'attaque maintenant
au bétail et ça risque d'avoir un impact
sur l'avenir des barbus gyan qui
dépendent de l'élevage des brebis et des
chèvres sévère certains c'est la seule
source de revenus qu'ils ont si des
chiens et tue tous quand ils reviendront
ils n'auront plus rien pour gagner leur
vie de vous protéger tout le monde et en
essayant de faire quelque chose pour
résoudre le problème des animaux on
aidera les humains aussi
barbuda commence à panser ses plaies et
à se reconstruire petit à petit mais la
tâche est immense
des centaines de maisons devront être
démolis puis rebâtie
sans école ni hôpital les barbots dire
ne pourront pas revenir
l'armée a lancé plusieurs opérations de
fumigation à cause des moustiques
porteurs du virus zika mais aussi de la
dengue plane la menace d'une épidémie
les pluies successives ces dernières
semaines ont inondé les champs les
maison envahie d'eau stagnante alors les
habitants s'organisent eux mêmes pour
sauver ce qui peut l'être
wilson et pêcheurs
allaient tirer tirer ces trois bateaux
ont été balayés par les ouragans il veut
les ramener antigua pour les réparer
toi mon bateau était ancré tout là-bas
et le vent la poussée jusqu ici
et vous avez une assurance pour
compenser vos pertes non l'économie va
mal
ça me permettre de payer une assurance
si je veux m'en sortir elle a mis au
jour le jour ici
alors maintenant on tente de voir ce que
l'on peut faire pour recommencer à
travailler non on ne peut pas attendre
mais parce qu'on ne sait pas quand on
recevra de l'aide mais peut-être que je
n'arriverais pas le réparer mais il faut
bien essayer de
ne pas se décourager et miser sur
l'avenir un pari pour la petite épicerie
de lille qui vient de rouvrir ses portes
quelques heures par jour
lille rose et son mari lincoln ont été
les premiers à acheter un générateur
pour faire fonctionner un petit
réfrigérateur et proposer des boissons
fraîches
c'est l'un des rares endroits de l'île
où les habitants peuvent se retrouver
pour bavarder
personne n'était autorisé à rester sur
l'île mais depuis quelques jours le
gouvernement permet exceptionnellement
aux commerçants de revenir s'installer
pour tenter de relancer leur activité
le plus important c'est que notre
communauté se reforme mais quand on dit
que l'on veut revenir sur lille les
autorités nous disent d'accord mais à
vos propres risques
donc les gens ne reviennent pas
je vais garder mon magasin ouvert pour
encourager les gens revenir à barbuda et
ses habitants ne veulent pas revenir car
il n'y a rien ici l'art d'aude
si on encourage les gens on reconstruira
bas monde est fou et nous avons besoin
des deux si aucune aide ne vient c'était
on n'y arrivera pas d'accord du fait
d'un gâteau en suspens et son
appartement
[Musique]
vont-ils réussir à reconstruire leur île
surtout arriveront ils à trouver
l'argent nécessaire
émue par le sort de barbuda un homme va
peut-être pouvoir leur venir en aide ce
matin le secrétaire général de l'onu est
attendu sur l'île
antonio goûter res arrive de new york le
voici en chemise bleue accompagné du
premier ministre gaston balande
juste après l'ouragan nous avons perdu
contact avec lille et vous savez je suis
venu la survoler en hélicoptère et quand
j'ai vu les dégâts je n'en ai pas cru
mes yeux
l'ancien ministre portugais aujourd'hui
chef de la diplomatie onusienne est un
fervent critique du changement
climatique on comment allez vous
monsieur
ma maison est juste au bout du chemin là
et je n'ai pas de générateurs vous
pouvez m'aider
ils habitent tous à antigua maintenant
votre toit s'est envolé où vous êtes
vous réfugier
m
moi je suis resté dans ma maison
parfois certains se sont aussi réfugiés
chez leurs voisins
et la plupart de ces maisons n'ont pas
d'assurance non la grande majorité non à
penser a toujours été comme cela ici et
c'est un problème
après une demi-heure de visite sous 35
degrés départ pour antigua le premier
ministre veut convaincre antonio
gutiérrez de faire pression sur l'onu
les accords de paris sur le climat signe
en 2015 prévoit la mise en place d'un
dôme nisation pertes et dommages pour
les pays les plus vulnérables comme
antigua et barbuda
mais les négociations traînent et gaston
balande le premier ministre veut obtenir
des fonds rapidement la présence du
secrétaire général de l'onu est une
opportunité à ne pas rater
[Musique]
ce n'est qu'une mission exploratoire je
ne pense pas qu'il soit venu pour signer
un chèque ou laisser important d'avoir
une voix forte pour parler en notre
faveur rendre les gens conscients de
notre tragédie est aussi j'espère nous
mettre en contact avec les bonnes
personnes pour tenter de mobiliser et
obtenir le soutien de la communauté
internationale
les conséquences dramatiques du
changement climatique c'est le cheval de
bataille du secrétaire général des
nations-unies c'est pour cette raison
qu'il a choisi de se rendre à barbuda
sans imaginer ce qu'ils allaient y
trouver
fg strict ne sera là je viens d'être
témoin d'un niveau de dévastation que je
n'avais jamais vu dans ma vie quand
j'étais dans des régions ravagées par
des conflits dans mon pays j'ai assisté
à des tremblements de terre des tempêtes
mais je n'ai jamais vu de telles
descriptions comme à barbuda
le lien entre le changement climatique
et les dévastations que nous observons
est clair et il ya une responsabilité
collective de la communauté
internationale pour stopper ces modes de
développement suicidaire
nous avons besoin d'un engagement fort
de la communauté internationale pour
arriver à dominer le changement
climatique et ainsi éviter ces désastres
dramatique à répétition qui seront
encore plus dramatique à l'avenir
une déclaration ferme mais cela
sera-t-il suffisant pour changer la
donne
la vie nations unies peuvent faire
quelque chose nous allons tout faire
tout ce que nous pouvons faire pour eux
réussir que tous les états puissent
non seulement
accomplir les objectifs définis par un
accord de paris mais aller plus loin
parce que l'accord de paris en soi même
n'est pas suffisante
l'accord de paris prévoit de limiter les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre pour
réduire l'impact du réchauffement
climatique de 2 degrés certainement pas
suffisant pour protéger les îles comme
barbuda des prochains jours à gants ni
pour financer sa reconstruction
et au calme
alors si antonio goûter reste n'arrive
pas à débloquer des aides financières
pourra-t-il mobiliser l'opinion
internationale
est ce que vous êtes satisfait de cette
visite franchement on recevoir quelqu'un
du calibre du secrétaire général des
nations unies il vient ton solidarité à
nos côtés pour nous soutient je pense
que c'est un succès remarquable
j'espère que son aide sera utile pour
rallier la communauté internationale et
nous aider à reconstruire
quand barbuda recevra-t-elle enfin de
l'aide
selon les ong internationale oxfam
l'année dernière plus de 23 millions de
personnes ont été contraintes de fuir
leurs terres à la suite de catastrophes
naturelles extrêmes les barbadiens sont
les derniers d'une longue liste qui ne
cesse de s'allonger
une vie d'exil et avec ce soir un match
de cricket organisée dans le stade dans
les tribunes et déplacés sont tous là
marianne la mère de famille en colère
denise la directrice taylor le menuisier
un spectacle devenu une routine pour ces
déplacés de barbuda
je pense qu'ils vont rester au moins
jusqu'en décembre et si c'est très
probable alors nous allons peut-être été
noël ensemble pour la première fois
cette situation temporaire est en train
de devenir définitive
oui c'est exactement ça car cela va
prendre beaucoup de temps pour
reconstruire barbuda a les mêmes s'ils
reviennent chez eux cela se fera par
étapes les pêcheurs en premier les
responsables locaux je dois pas un
retour massif pour tous les suisses
[Musique]
sur la pelouse le match continue les
points s'enchaînent mais les parodiens
n'ont pas le coeur à la compétition ce
soir
[Musique]
un jour viendra où cela nous rendra plus
fort aujourd'hui nous devons être forts
pour endurer ces semaines c'est moi loin
de chez nous dans un refuge dans des
conditions que nous n'avions jamais vécu
avant
mais je crois que tout cela nous rendra
plus fort encore
[Musique]
un sourire pour effacer le doute la peur
de ne jamais revenir sur barbuda lille
fantôme désertée de ses habitants
aujourd'hui perdu loin de chez eux
[Musique]
ils le savent les ouragans vont se
répéter
en raison du réchauffement climatique
ils vont devenir plus fréquent est
encore plus violent dans les caraïbes
[Musique]
une menace existentielle paix sur
barbuda
ces habitants vont-ils subir un exil
inéluctable
non
[Musique]
on